i have a very strange video that is
quickly becoming one of my favorite
clips of the week this is
i don't even know how to explain this
donald trump did an event yesterday
instead of just hiding it was good to
see him do something he did a
presidential medal of freedom ceremony
for dan
gable who's a wrestler and coach and
as the event was sort of winding down
the press assembled and was starting to
ask trump questions
and in the video i'm going to play for
you you will hear a question asked of
donald trump about whether he will go to
joe biden's inauguration
and trump just sort of looked around
confused i guess
realized he didn't want to answer that
question and just walked out of the room
and you can tell from the video that
people are confused about why donald
trump is leaving
and the camera weirdly cuts to dan gable
who's the presidential medal honoree
who looks very confused and says
he's gone because clearly no one
expected such an abrupt ending to this
event it's some of the strangest
behavior we've seen
um take a look at this it's just
absolute gold
mr president one more question about the
inauguration thank you very much
anything i'm bill boster
congratulations he's gone
it really seems like the uh curvier
enthusiasm theme should be playing as
donald trump one
walks out it's comical and bizarre
and unexplainable all at once and the
simplest explanation is trump's
trump continues not to want to answer
questions like
do you admit you lost and do you concede
that joe biden will be president
and will you be going to the
inauguration and there was really no way
to stay in the room without
answering the questions as far as trump
was concerned but the truth is
a real president could have handled this
very easily
and stayed in the room without answering
those questions trump could have said
hey listen guys we're here today to
honor dan
we're celebrating dan's incredible
accomplishments i don't know what they
are but but he presumably does
i'm just not familiar with dan gable and
he could say
this isn't a time for politics it's not
a time for questions
thank you very much you're still
avoiding the questions but you're doing
it in a slightly more reasonable way
trump can't do it or at least he doesn't
behave in that way and
instead just kind of bizarrely wanders
off leaving
a room full of people and everything
about this event was was a total farce
at one point while the event is going on
there's a little kid laying down
looks like he's sleeping in the back of
the oval office or whatever room this
was in
all completely bizarre and of course
trump supporters will defend him no
matter what and say well
listen the fake news media
was throwing unfair mean questions at
him
it was presidential harassment and
uh if you think that's crazy dan gable
was actually
interviewed this morning about this
bizarre event
and he essentially said that which was
trump didn't want to answer those
questions
truly strange times take a look i think
donald trump
really respects me he's always been
humbled in front of me
he's never made me mad he might have
walked out of the press conference a
little bit
yesterday a little bit perturbed with a
couple
newspaper newspaper people but but hey
i was having a great time he left you in
the office by yourself with your family
that's okay he uh he uh he was didn't
like what was going on
he thought he said it was about me and
it wasn't about him so he's
i'm out of there you got it no i hear
you and you have the medal with you
i i certainly i do right here can we see
it right here yep
uh yeah right here it's the it's uh
president's medal of freedom right here
yeah
so uh what a weird timeline that we are
in
and um i know some people have been
writing to me saying
trump is comedy gold david i'm really
going to miss trump
when he leaves office stuff like this
i guess is funny in a relatively benign
way
and i will sort of miss it but the
country and the world are going to be so
much better off with trump gone and
we're down to just six weeks we're all
looking forward to it
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you
25 off your first order it's made with
four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video